pero impunidad fue la respuesta del
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador a
las críticas luego del asesinato de
armando linares director del medio
monitor michoacán quien fue atacado en
su casa frente a su familia es el octavo
asesinato de un comunicador en mexico en
lo corrido de 2022 en un país en el que
el 95% de los crímenes quedan en la
impunidad ya estábamos
haciendo la investigación se les va a
informar dos cosas les adelanto una
qué
no son crímenes de estado
nunca jamás nosotros vamos a mandar a
matar a nadie
ya no es el tiempo de el mátalos en
caliente
primero
y segundo cero impunidad
linares venía denunciando amenazas
contra su vida por parte de funcionarios
tras el asesinato en enero de un colega
del mismo medio roberto toledo tras
haber revelado corrupción de
funcionarios estatales con mucha
impotencia principalmente en potencia
[Música]
pues que en este caso nosotros no hace
nada no hay nada al respecto nada previo
nada
antes durante y después según cifras
oficiales hasta 2021 691 periodistas
amenazados estaban bajo el mecanismo de
protección de las autoridades mexicanas
tanto el secretario de estado de eeuu
anthony blinken como el parlamento
europeo pidieron acciones al mandatario
mexicano contra la impunidad en los
crímenes contra los reporteros en las
últimas tres décadas van más de 140
homicidios de periodistas y según
reporteros sin fronteras méxico es uno
de los países más peligrosos del mundo
para ejercer la profesión
[Música]